it would actually be cool like
i should consider like reaching out to
some uh
like maybe grandmaster streamers
that would be up for doing an on-stream
lesson the car would be awesome but i
don't know if you'd be after that one
song for the rest of your life what
would it be
wait for it wait for it
wait for it
here's your answer
oh min lay too yeah mainly
i had a match with minlae and then like
a whole
like analysis lesson afterwards
the whole thing's on youtube
it was like two and a half hours long
oh i'm on two
okay i'll play one bullet game hopefully
i can time the bullet game for when the
song ends
so we are
44 some seconds in
i will start a bullet game in
i should probably join the pool now
right
i don't know about the timing though
let's join the pool now
it's heating up
i gotta go soon
okay
we're playing
playing fire lord zuko
joe bava london time oh we're playing
into the same almost not quite the same
line
opponent knows what they're doing
or do they
[Music]
okay for the center break want to play
e5 and fork the pieces
oop oh
center is opening up
queen is hit and the bishop says
oh no box material
oh no blocks queen
oh yes my position
if castling i win h7
i want to play g5
okay
attack
is carrying through
i'm threading maiden one
[Music]
i want a queen sack can i do it please
let me do it
oh look at this
hey
my opponent didn't let me play it out
but i could have taken
taken
and then under promote to bishop with
checkmates
i could have won a rosen trophy
my opponent deprived me of the majestic
promote to bishop with checkmate
i'm so sad now